space above and beyond a series before
its time but could it still be in line
to get a reboot welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
so a few months ago I told you that
Disney were considering seriously
considering a space above and beyond
reboot instead of Firefly
they were looking very seriously for a
new Sci-Fi franchise now the Orville
might be that franchise that they want a
utopian style Sci-Fi show a good feeling
show but they also want something a
little darker and a little heavier now
they'd have loved that to have been the
Firefly but when they tried to develop
something they just couldn't figure out
how to do it they asked for several
different creators to pitch ideas and
just nothing worked so instead they
decided to look at something else in
their stable and the first thing they
looked at was space above and beyond but
that was a few months ago now what is
happening well I can tell you that
sources that are close to people
potentially developing this show are
telling me that things are still moving
in the right direction now initially
Disney asked a couple of different
create just to pitch some ideas for a
space above and beyond and that didn't
really go anywhere quite quickly so they
had the very bright idea of returning to
the original producers Glenn Morgan and
James Wong were the initial creators of
space above and beyond and they had
before that worked on the X-Files and
since worked on several other projects
so Disney approached them and said you
know would you like to bring this show
back apparently both producers James
Wong would go on to write the series
jumped at the opportunity now this isn't
going as far as being green lit yet all
they've been asked to do is pitch ideas
for how the series would go ahead but
what I'm being told is there that is
really a difficult process they already
know what they would like to do with the
series because they'd already mapped out
five seasons previously
space above meyond was always supposed
to be a five season series but obviously
it got canceled after the first so all
that James Wong would have to do as the
writer was take the original story that
they had and potentially revamp it a
little bit maybe modernized a little bit
and that's all they intend to do we're
actually going to be able to find out
what would have happened Beyond season
one now this is not going to be what I'm
being told is a continuation this is
going to be a little bit like what JMS
Jane Michael schizinski has been asked
to do with Babylon 5. it's basically a
reimagining it's kind of like they're
going to go to the original creators and
go you know if you were to do the show
now what would you do and that's the
opportunity they're being given now I
think this is actually a brilliant and
quite a brave thing for a TV production
complete Disney this is actually going
to be through Fox though
um to do because this show has already
failed once so why would they assume
that it would work this time well as I
said space above and beyond was just
ahead of its time it's one of those
shows that you know now if it was on a
streaming service would have got 50 or
60 hours worth of Television out of now
I don't think this is the type of show
that goes on a network it's not a 22-24
episode a year series and that there's
something they can produce a series
every single year it's too big in scale
and that was one of the problems
responsible and Beyond before that it
was on a network they never were able to
fulfill the possibilities of a show like
this on the limitations of a network a
network we get lots of hours of
Television you know 40 minute episodes
22 Episodes plus but we don't
necessarily get the quality now if
Disney Fox decide to go ahead with this
and we do get a space above and beyond
reboot I think we can look forward to
something really exciting and if we do
get four five seasons 40 or 50 hours of
Television I think they would have the
opportunity to tell a really exciting
and interesting story as I said this is
very much like what JMS is doing with
Babylon 5. when he has said why do you
want to do it again he said well I just
want to know what I would now do with it
I'm a wiser man I'm an older man after
all of the projects I've done in the
past all of the experience I've gathered
what would I do with bubble R5 now James
Wong and Glenn Morgan have exactly the
same opportunity so let's hope they
grasp it with both hands and produce
something that's even better than the
original and if you actually now think
about it and you look back on that
season how many shows have copied it
since and that is always a big sign of
really great TV
so guys get in the comments and tell me
exactly what you think is space above
and beyond something you want to see
given a second chance now generally
speaking we don't really love reboots on
this channel we tend to bemoan them and
wish they would just do something
different instead but some projects
deserve a reboot and for me space above
and beyond is 100 one of those
but get in the comments and tell me what
you think if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe that Bell
notification really helps us out and as
always please consider hitting the join
button if you want to really support the
channel as always please stay safe and
I'll see you next time
[Music]